hello everyone and welcome to an
absolutely astonishing game from the
first round of the ancient rapid
Knockouts 2022 these are the
quarterfinals and it is Arjun Eric AC
versus Magnus Carlsen uh it's it's a
spectacular game really uh I mean
you guys will just have to see what
happened in this one it's like some 140
moves but it's incredible it's pure
action all the way and uh let's dive
straight into it Arjun has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to E4
Magnus goes for the Sicilian Defense
spawn to C5 Knight to F3 we have found
the E6 and the D4 so standard stuff here
captures characters Knights to C6 Knight
to C3 and now Queen to C7 the boss
record variation of the taiman of
Sicilian and now there are many moves
that are popular here Bishop T2 can be
played Bishop to E3 can be played Knight
D to B5 can be played and the many other
moves the move uh that are June plays is
only the 13th most popular move and he
plays Knight seat the B5 and here of
course Magnus had to spend some time as
that doesn't matter how good your
opening knowledge is you do not know the
continuation on the 13th most popular
move and of course you you have to start
calculating because there are a lot of
things to consider if you go something
like Queen to E5 then let's say queen to
D3 you guard your Pawn here and then
well what is happening here is is F4
coming do you have to trade on D4 that's
too much stuff to calculate in in a
rapid game so instead a magnet just goes
back Queen to B8 this has to be good of
course you're gonna kick away the knight
at some point
and now Bishop to D3 and there are some
games where Knight the E5 was played
also A6 is a normal night gt7 is a
normal but here Magnus plays Knight to
F6 and it is now already as of move 7
that we have a completely new game and
where our game truly begins so here are
Arjun castles and now Pawn to A6 by
Magnus the Magnus already burned quite a
lot of time here he spent some five
minutes up and go up until this point
and Arjun just blitzed everything out
some 15 minutes on the clock for Arjun
and Magnus has some 10 minutes on the
clock and this is the idea Knight
captures Big D captures on C6 and now
this Knight comes to D4 with Bishop to
D6 now Magnus puts pressure on the H2
Pawn so now you have to defend it and
now Knight back to F3 defending the H2
pawn and here uh Magnus has to decide
how to continue does he cancel does he
play something like Queen back to C7
does he uh does he what what can he do
he plays Pawn to E5 which opens up the
light score Bishop but it kind of blocks
the queen and the dark Square Bishop so
now obviously he has something planned
for this with Bishop to G5 and now
Bishop to E6 he is offering Bishop
caterson on F6 the double up his F Pawn
but then he will get the semi-open G
file for the attack and Arjun goes for
it Bishop captures on F6 G captures and
now Knights the H for preparing to put
the Knight on F5 because uh well once
you see this against the Sicilian you
just know it always works because the
characters captures leaving white with a
light Square Bishop never turns out
great for black so here Queen to C7 you
want to either Castle Queen side or
bring the Rook into the game and now
Queen to F3 putting pressure on the F6
pawn and Magnus defends at Bishop to E7
now also interesting here would be just
the castle Queen side give up the pawn
and say okay this game is not about
pawns but Magnus for the moment defends
it also uh if the F Pawn uh moves you
will be guarding some of the squares
here so maybe that's that has something
to do with it but okay Knight to F5 we
have Queen side Castles by Magnus and
now Rook F to D1 we have Pawn to H5 now
going for the attack but also Arjun
plays H4 and now this Pawn here uh will
be weak if the move if the Rook ever
moves from h8 and now Bishop to C5 and
here the clock time pretty much
equalized both of them are now on 10
minutes so now Arjun had to spend some
time to try and see how to take the most
out of the position uh and he plays Pawn
to B3 now of course
um this is not what the engine likes the
engine likes A3 and C3 because It
prepares the strongest move Pawn to B4
but okay here Pawn to B3 and now King to
B8 by Magnus a nice prophylactic move
and now Bishop C4 this is the point
behind B3 you want to challenge magnus's
uh Bishop on E6 and also his Bishop
capture spawn captures you do get the
semi-open B file to start an attack
against the black king but this isn't so
bad for Magnus for example captures
captures Queen A5 now puts pressure on
the A2 Pawn also has very nice control
over this diagonal and if let's say Rook
to D3 you want to undouble your pawns
black can even just capture and play
Queen to D2 so something like this but
Magnus goes Rook D to G8 he wants to go
for the attack also he has some very
nice plans as the bishop here is
attacking F2 he has some planes of Rook
to G4 Rook to F4 putting pressure on F2
which will force Arjun to play g3 at
some point to prevent Rook to F4 but
that will further weaken the king's side
and okay King to F1 nothing spectacular
here so there's nothing Concrete in the
position but the clock is ticking so you
have to you have to play something Rook
to G4 by Magnus and now Pawn to G3 as
plan preventing Rook to F4 and now Rook
back to d8 it's hard for for Magnus not
to break through and he he needs to play
something and if Arjun wanted he could
just trade for example captures captures
he brings the Rook into the game for
free attacks the queen but now there's
this very nasty Bishop captures check uh
upon captures and the queen comes to A5
and it's a very nice position for both
white and black white should always be
better but uh again a very very
unbalanced and very double-edged so
after Rook to d8 we have pawned the A4
by Arjun and now King the A7
uh we have root character 78 now the
trade happens Queen captures Rook to D1
and now uh uh you you don't really want
to trade the bishop but if you move the
queen let's say queen to C7 then Knight
the E3 comes the bishop here is defended
and okay the rock is under attack so
yeah you're just gonna have a much
better position so Magnus goes for it
Bishop captures on C4 B captures and now
Queen to B6 not putting constant
pressure on F2 so the queen kinda has to
stay here uh guarding the F2 Pawn uh but
Arjun plays King to G2 this will work
well for him as uh well once the Knight
moves you you want uh uh more pieces
defending the F2 and G3 pawns we have
Queen to B4 by Magnus now putting
pressure on the pawns here and not
Knight the H6 this is in fact the best
move attacking the rook and the pawn
here and you don't really care what
Magnus is doing on the queen side so
Rook G7 defending the pawn and now it
would be it would be a great mistake
capture on F6 if you do this Rook G6 and
you've just blundered the Knight so
instead Queen to B3 the absolute best
move by arjune this uh forces the queen
trade unless Magnus does something
really really uh weird because where do
you move the queen it's it's it's uh
it's such a a funny position because if
the Queen ever moves from from the B
file Rook to D7 will put pressure on B7
and there's just not much you can do
here you could play A5 this is one of
the options you just defend like this
but then Knight to F5 attacks the rook
and once The Rook moves now comes Rook
to D7 again pretty much with the same
idea the queen cannot move because of
Checkmate if you could you would love to
bring your queen here threaten the F2
Pawn that's just not happening also the
F7 Pawn is hanging so it's uh a very bad
position for black so Magnus plays Rook
the H7 he attacks the Knight and now the
situation on the clock is three minutes
for Arjun and two minutes for Magnus uh
and here Arjun goes for the trade Queen
captures on B4 Bishop counters and now
Knight to G8 he will now collect the F6
pawn and there is nothing Magnus can do
about it so Magnus has to figure out how
to find some counter Play Because pawns
will just start
dropping so King to B6 he goes after the
A4 Pawn if he collects it then he has
created a past a pawn so maybe he can
start pushing that to create some
counter play we have rooked the D7 not
in a rush to Capron F6 now just says
okay you move the king I'm gonna start
collecting on the queen side as well and
okay Magnus really without a choice here
King the A5 we have Rook counters on B7
King captures an A4 now Magnus does
create a pass pawn and now Knight
captures on F6 attacking The Rook Rook
to H6 attacking the Knight and now
Knights the D7 and uh again it's a very
very tricky position here if you try
something like Bishop to C5 to defend
the E5 Pawn then Knight the C5 check is
very annoying attacking the A6 pawn and
if you defend it the then your king is
just completely boxed in there's really
no nowhere for you to go it's uh such a
such an ugly position all all of the
squares are taken away from the black
king and it will just be a slow painful
death so after Knight the D7 A5 by
Magnus uh not only adding more defense
to the bishop but also advancing that
pass Pawn you do want to push it at some
point but Arjun says nope that's not
happening Pawn to C3 absolute uh Master
Class by Arjun here completely taking
away all the squares from the bishop
point is that if Bishop captures then
Knight to the C5 check and now after the
only move King A3 Rook B3 check just
picks up the bishop so that's the idea
so Magnus cannot collect on C3 he has to
play Bishop to A3 and now Pawn to C5
boxing in uh the king and Bishop
completely and the problem is uh if you
don't move the king and Bishop you are
never gonna start pushing your past Pawn
so Magnus has to try Bishop to C1 but
now Rook to be E1 again beautifully
played and now if the bishop goes back
Knight the B6 is just Checkmate that's
uh one of only one of the problems if
you don't go back what else can you do
if you play Bishop to D2 then there's
this very nasty Knight B6 check King A3
Knight to C4 check connecting with the
bishop and even if you attack The Rook
just Rook the B to check uh capturing
the bishop so the bishop hangs whatever
you do so Magnus tries King to A3 he
hangs the bishop voluntarily now trying
to get some ideas if Rook captures on C1
then King to King to B2 and then after
the Rook moves at least he can start
pushing his Pawn maybe he can he can do
something uh objectively the position is
winning for Arjun but it does seem that
it offers some counter play and Magnus
was able to convince Arjun that he
should not uh he he should not capture
that that bishop and C1 so Arjun plays
something else he plays Knight captures
on E5 and now Magnus quickly plays best
of the B2 we have knighted the C4 with
check now connecting nicely with the
bishop now King to B3 Magnus just uh you
know pulling rabbits out of a hat and
like so many rabbits like uh I I don't
know when was the last time we've seen
so many many rabbits pulled out of a hat
in one game now again uh you can't
really capture if you capture with the
Rook then King captures um first on C3
still the Knight will be attacked for
example a rook captures on B2 first king
can capture on C3 collect the pawn and
still the rook and Knight are attacked
so you're gonna win back the piece so
that's one way to do it and if you play
Knight captures then Magnus has King to
A2 plant again attacking The Rook end
the Knight and you will collect your
piece back so instead uh instead of this
um capture we have Knight captures on A5
with check this is the best move for
Arjun King to C2 and now Rook to E1 and
now we have Bishop captures and C3
attacking the Knight and the Rook here
but luckily you have Rook to E2 with
check King to D3 attacks The Rook Here
and Now Rook the E3 with check with King
to D4 and now Knight back to B7 finally
getting that Knight out of Harm's Way
But if you can't material Arjun is up to
pawn so he didn't grab the bishop but uh
being up to Pawns of course that is
completely winning so Bishop to B4
Magnus goes after the C5 not now Rook
the F3 Magnus Arjun goes for the F7 pawn
pawn to F6 Magnus defends it and now
Rook to F4 we have Bishop to D2 now
attacking the rook and just Rook to F5
we have King captures on e4 and now
Knight the D6 with check uh attacking
the king defending the Rook King to D4
and not Knight the E8 this is how he
wins back his material uh the F6 Pawn
will now fall Rook the h8 and Knight
captures on F6
now again Arjun is up to pawns and
Magnus uh well he he can resign but of
course he will he will fight this is
only move 50 and like we said this game
will last for like a hundred more moves
so Rook another Rook The d8 Rook the f8
was played here so the Knight cannot
move the Rook is undefended Arjun just
brings The Rook back Rook to F3 and now
Rook they trade Magnus says alright I
know I'm lost but you still have to beat
me so beat me and now Rook to F5 putting
pressure on the H5 Pawn now just Rogue
back to a f8 preventing The Rook or
Knight capturing on H5 as uh well there
are uh their stuff attacked and EF file
King to F3 now Arjun has to start
bringing the king into the game now
Bishop to H6 by Magnus uh we have Pawn
to G4 now of course he wants to start
pushing H characters King captures now
Rook to F7 we have Pawn to F3 and now
Rook the G7 with check with King the H5
and now Bishop back to E3 so okay uh
still still keeping that white king uh
stuck in the corner maybe he can still
try and hope for a blunder from Arjun
Knight the E4 we have King to D3 and now
Rook the F6 going after the pawn here uh
now King to E2 saying okay you grab that
I'm gonna grab the the F3 Pawn so Knight
to G5 defending the pawn and now just
Bishop captures on C5 Rook captures on
C6 and now Bishop back to E3 so now
Magnus zero pawns are June 2 past pawns
we have King the G4 Rook to A7 and now
we have Rook the E6 Arjuna has to put
his pieces on optimal squares and then
start pushing those pawns and Magnus
will will hope hope for something we
have King to D3 with Ponte H5 the the
pawns start marching forward and now
Rook the A1 it starts time to start
checking the white king from behind uh
Pawn to F4 and now Rook the G1 with
check King the F5 now the H1 and rooked
D6 now with check we have King to C4
now with ideas of Rook to H4 going after
the F4 pawn and it's uh hard to see how
how you can prevent this there is one
way you could do it if you play Rook the
H6 but it's not a move you want to play
especially in a rapid game you're under
a minute you do not want to block your
own Pawn the idea being that now okay
you can play Rook to H4 but now you can
defend the pawn Knights the E6 and now
everything is defended this is defended
this is defended and now you can just
maybe play a rookie shade start pushing
that pawn improve your position and so
on but Arjun doesn't play it he plays
Pawn to H6 and now okay Magnus can only
take what is offered he plays The Rook
to H4 goes after the F4 pawn and pawn to
H7 so Arjun gives up one Pawn but he has
a pass Pawn on H7 uh ready to be
promoted to a queen so not The Rook
captures but Bishop captures on F4 and
now Rook to D7 uh Rook the E6 is much
much cleaner Rook the E6 and there's
really no defense against this Rook the
E4 idea there's too much stuff on the
fourth Rank and uh well you're just
gonna have to give up something so after
this Rook to D7 by Arjun and now Bishop
to E3 now Magnus can still hope to fight
with King the G6 now the pawn is
protected Arjun wants to play Rook to d8
and uh uh Queen the pawn now Rook to H1
with Knight to F3 and now we have Rook
the H3 attacking the Knight Knight the
E5 check King to C5 and Rook d8 now
preparing to advance that pawn and now
we have Bishop to D4 and here uh amazing
as it is uh we are already at move 75
the position is now completely winning
for Arjun and it has been throughout the
entire game but now uh Magnus by by uh
so so viciously defending so so
vigorously uh he he was able to create a
position where only one move is winning
for Arjun not like 10 uh like like it
was so far uh so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this
incredible finesse while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to D3 with check that's that's
the good stuff and now whatever you do
uh you're just gonna win the game to
give you some ideas uh let's say you go
Rook captures on D3 okay the Knight
obviously can be captured but now the
Rook no longer guards the h8 square so
now you play Rook capture Sandy for you
eliminate the defender of the h8 square
which is the bishop and even if the Rook
comes back to help out this row goes
back as well and now you Queen the pawn
on the next move so that doesn't work if
after Knight the D3 check you just move
the king and now okay you you do not
move the Rook away from the uh from from
the defense of the h8 square it doesn't
really matter because now you can just
play Rook uh for example Knight the F4
you attack The Rook here and uh there
are a couple of options here obviously
you can go Rook back to H1 if you play
something like Rook to H1 uh then the
night the or even better Rook captures
on D4 with check King captures Knight H5
now blocks the rook's reach uh to the h8
square and that's it next move you just
Queen the pawn or if you don't go uh
Rook to each one you could go Rook to G3
with check doesn't really matter King to
F5 and now uh what do you do if you go
Bishop to A1 to keep an eye on the
Square because if a trade Bishop
counters and Rook counters yes you do
win the bishop but you can no longer win
the game Rook vs rook and Knight is a
draw uh I forgot to mention this as uh
you know I always think you guys know
everything so after Rook to A8 uh for
example going after the bishop there's
no good Square for the bishop if Bishop
to B2 just Rook the C8 with check and if
King to D4 uh now just Knight to E2
collecting The Rook or if you go King
anywhere on the B file then Rook to B8
with check picking up the bishop
eliminating the defender of the h8
square you just Queen the pawn so that's
what's what uh Knight the D3 check just
winning here but Arjun doesn't play it
he plays the seemingly winning move he
plays Knights the G4 of course the idea
is just play Knight H6 The Rook no
longer has the control over the h8
square but it is not enough now Magnus
says this one tempo to prevent a rook
captures on D4 and now of course Magnus
finds it Rook to A1 and now how do you
win this uh the problem is now if you go
Rook if you go this uh Knight stage sex
move you can just start checking Rook to
G3 check and after King the F5 now you
play Rook the H3 and of course you know
that
um the the If You Queen the pawn the end
game will be a draw but just Bishop
captures real captors and this is a draw
there's no winning this and if you don't
uh well there's really not all that much
you can try uh uh after this uh Rook to
H3 you can just repeat you can go for
example King to G for another characters
on H6 that's it no no where is there so
instead Rook the A8 by Arjun now going
after the bishop and now Bishop to B2 we
have broke the d8 and now Magnus just
plays Rook to G3 how do you how do you
play here you can't promote you have to
defend the Knight so King has to go back
now Rook H3 now Magnus has Fern control
over the h8 square and he is not afraid
to give up a bishop even for that pawn
so Rook to D7 and now Bishop to h8 now
Magnus all he has to do basically to
survive this
is keep the bishop the rook and king as
far away from each other as possible you
do not want to run into a night Fork if
you've already defended the game up
opted up until this point so King to G6
Rook to G3 again going after the Knight
now Rook to d8 a very very tricky idea
uh the idea is of course that if the
Knight is captured then King to H5 but
still yeah I mean it's it's not much
you're just gonna play something like
Rook to G7 and that's it even if Rook
captures uh this is not a problem this
is a draw you will not allow a check and
it's still just a drive King to B7 Rook
to C6 check you can never win this if
King goes here you're just gonna play
Rook to C7 check if King goes here
you're just gonna continue checking
there's nothing to worry about uh so
after this Rook 38 move just Bishop back
to A1 by Magnus and now we have King to
G5 Rook to H3 again and Knight to H6 now
okay you you have control over the uh h8
square but still you don't have a way to
give up The Rook for the bishop so Rook
the G3 check now King the F5 uh sorry
King to F5 if Rook to H4 you don't care
Rook G1 and again h8 Queen is nothing so
instead we have King to F5 Rook to H3
and now King to G5 Rook to G3 check King
to H4 and The Rook to G1 so here we have
Rook the G8 uh offering a rook trade but
of course just The Rook to H1 check King
G5 Rook to G1 checking to H5 uh Magnus
now very very happy with himself Rook to
H1 tracking the G6 we have Rook to G1
check King to F7 and now Rook the F1
with check King to E7 Rook to E1 check
King to D7 Rook the D1 check and King to
C8 so now Arjun escapes checks but it
doesn't matter just we'll go back to H1
attacks the Knight so Rook to G6
defending the Knight but not just King
to D5 again there's not much you can do
here King to D7 and now Bishop the C 3
just waiting for Arjun to figure out
what he wants to try next king D7 Rogue
back to A1 like we said keeping
everything away as possible from each
other and now Rook the G5 with check if
you try Knight to F7 it doesn't really
matter you're just gonna play Rook D7
with track and after the king moves Rook
a to check also the bishop covers this
so you're just gonna go back and now we
just repeat so after Rook A1 Rook the G5
check King to E4 and now Knight to F7
reaching move 100 but again not much to
it Rook the H1 we have Rook the G3 now
attacking the bishop and the just Rook
captures on H7 now Magnus says alright
uh you have to do something otherwise it
will be a draw due to the 50 move rule
so Rook captures on C3 and now Arjun has
50 moves the Checkmate Magnus Carlson if
he is unable to do it then it will be a
draw soaking to D4
uh Rook Dev 3 and now King the E4 again
harassing The Rook Rook to F6 and Rook
to H1 again keep your king and Rook as
far away from each other as possible so
so you know you you don't have one or a
fork or something King the E6 now Rook
the A1 we have Knights the D6 with check
King to E3 and now Rook to H6 we have
rooked A6 now not allowing the Knight to
move Rook to H4 and Rook the A1 we have
knighted the C4 with check okay pushing
the blacking uh a bit further backing F3
knocking the F5 and now even the
beautiful Rook F1 Magnus even makes a
joke here uh sort of offering Knight to
D to check a nice Fork to win The Rook
the problem is if you do this check uh
then comes this check and then the Rook
Falls and then if Knight captures an F1
with the check King captures an H4 and
it's a draw by insufficient material so
I have to Rook F1 we have Rook back to
h8 King to G3 check King to G5 and now
Rook the C1 and now it's merely a matter
of technique and not much really
happening here 95 Rook to C5 again going
after the Knight King F5 Rook A5 Rook
the B8 King F2 Rook the B3 and now King
to E2 with King to E4 trying to box in
the black king but just Rook to A4 with
check King D5 now Rook A5 checking D4
rookie four check Knight the C4 and now
Rook to A8 so once the Knight moves to
help out with the defense from all the
checks then you move the Rook back as
far away from the King and now you will
use this file uh to start checking the
white king so here King T4 now Rook the
E8 we checked 95 now King to D2 We have
rooked the D3 check King C2 Rook to D7
now just Rook the h8 you can check the
white king from anywhere Rook to C7
checking B3 King to D4 and now Rook to
H4 with King D5 Rook to H5 not allowing
the knights to move
and now Rook the C8 Rook the H1 Knight
to F3 and now Rook back to H5 with check
King D4 we have Rook to H7 Knight to D2
check and the King to B2 so while it is
possible to play 20 more moves until
they reach the 50 move rule Arjun said
all right I've had it I've had it you
you can have your draw and we have a
nice repetition of moves here King D3
Rook H3 check King D4 Rook H4 truck King
D3 Rook H3 check King D4 rookage four
check and I'm gonna make the final move
with the mouse just you know to make it
uh awesome King to D3 and it was in this
uh a position on
136 that Arjun irrigation Magnus Carlsen
agreed to a draw or rather it's a draw
by threefold repetition
so there we have a truly a spectacular
game Arjun absolutely crushing Magnus in
the opening he surprised him completely
with this Knight seat the B5 move like I
said the 13th most popular option here
in this position so no way Magnus is
prepared for this uh and Arjun gets a
brilliant position he he gets a
completely winning position and uh well
he he he's grinding it he's grinding it
I don't think we can even call this the
Magnus effect because Arjun didn't
really do anything wrong he just uh I
mean
Magnus just put up such a such a
stubborn defense that uh I mean he he he
was willing to defend this for
everything it was basically an engine
level defense like when we've covered
the games between stock Vision Alpha
zero okay stockfish is now winning where
Alpha zero is winning and then it takes
a hundred more more moves to actually
convert the win so it's possible to
defend well only we rarely see it on a
human level but here you've seen what it
looks like when you actually defend in
the position for 100 moves where you are
completely lost and then okay maybe not
100 but 50 moves were completely lost
and then yeah it all came down to this
point which I'm sure you guys figured
out Knight to D3 uh where Magnus was
able to take the position uh here where
only one move was winning for Arjun and
he he he wasn't able to find it due to a
severe time pressure but yeah incredible
game by both of them uh outstanding
preparation and you know just uh I mean
beautiful stuff by Arjun I I really hope
he he manages to play at this level it's
absolutely stunning to watch uh such a
such brilliancy but also Magnus enduring
all of this and in the end not losing uh
are definitely commendable uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh like as part of said in the in the
end games the gods have placed Magnus
Carlsen and he proves it once again so
there you have it started the end game
it is what chess is basically about uh I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to Jimmy LeBlanc and I would like to
thank Anderson Vera torko stanquist a
ravishing reptiles YouTube and Trevor
Terrace for a contribution to my channel
think a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event until
it finishes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and sorry for a bit of a longer
video but it is 136 moves see you soon